o
[Música]
a la editorial marvel cómics le encanta
agregar personajes en forma de dioses a
sus historias tienen dioses para todo el
dios del rayo el dios de las mentiras el
dios de las referencias demonios hasta
tienen a un dios del baile
[Música]
pero cuando marvel se cansó de tantos
dioses en sus historias decidió crear un
personaje que los acabaría a todos les
presento a word el carnicero de dioses
gore es uno de los enemigos más
poderosos con los que se ha enfrentado
autor a lo largo de sus incontables
historias y a pesar de que se mataba a
dioses tiene una historia bastante
triste que aunque no justifica lo que
hizo por lo menos hace que podamos
entender por qué lo hace además de que
la historia es genial tiene muchas
peleas asombrosas y en general es de las
mejores historias de zorro
la historia de gor comienza hace miles
de años en un planeta desconocido en
donde la vida era muy difícil todo en
este planeta quería matarte pues más
allá de ser un mundo lleno de animales
muy peligrosos y con el planeta como tal
siendo muy inestable el hambre y la
pobreza abundaban y el solo hecho de
mantenerse con vida era complicado en
este planeta nació un pequeño niño a
quien conoceríamos como gorro a quien
desde muy pequeño se le enseñó a creer
ya adorar a los dioses pues su gente
creía que algún día los dioses
escucharía en sus oraciones y los
ayudarían aunque claro los dioses nunca
los ayudaron por desde muy pequeño vivió
rodeado de muerte y tristeza pues cuando
era solamente un niño sus padres
murieron tratando de protegerlo de las
criaturas del planeta quedándose
completamente solo
[Música]
con el pasar de los años work
conseguiría una esposa y tendría un par
de hijos pero el destino es cruel y
durante un terremoto gol perdería a casi
todos sus hijos y a su esposa quien
estaba embarazada como si esto fuera
poco luego de un tiempo el único hijo
restante de word moriría de hambre
enloquecido por la tristeza y la rabia
por maldice a los dioses y niega su
existencia pues si existiera un dios no
los dejaría sufrir de esta manera al
escuchar esta blasfemia gor sería
exiliado de su tribu y pasaría muchos
días vagando por el mundo rogando porque
su muerte llegará pronto de repente
mientras go vagaba sin rumbo presenció
una bola de fuego que cayó desde el
cielo al acercarse pudo ver a dos dioses
que habían caído mientras peleaban uno
de estos dioses resultó ser null de
quien tengo todo un vídeo dedicado a él
para que le eches un vistazo
al acercarse a estos dioses por la
arrebato anula negro espada un arma
simbionte que tiene un inmenso poder
esta poderosa arma comenzó a corromper
aún más la mente ya enloquecida de gorra
así que cuando gor se dio cuenta del
gran poder que había adquirido decidió
marcharse jurando tomar venganza y
asesinar a todos los dioses en
existencia
[Música]
ahora si no has visto mi vídeo de nul
muy mal hecho qué vergüenza deberías ir
a verlo y luego volver a este vídeo pero
si no has visto este vídeo ahora te
explicaré brevemente que es la micro
espada también conocida como all blacks
esta poderosa arma no es solamente una
espada pues al fundirse con su portador
de otorga a su usuario una enorme fuerza
y resistencia y puede cubrirlo con un
manto que lo protege de cualquier daño
además la necro espada hacer el primer
simbionte en la existencia puede cambiar
su forma usándose como un arma o incluso
creando criaturas de la oscuridad la
necro espada es una arma ya de por sí
poderosa ya que tiene el poder
suficiente como para matar un celestial
pero puede volverse aún más poderosa
pues la necro espada absorbe la energía
de cada enemigo al que asesina volviendo
la cada vez más fuerte así que si gore
estaba
por cientos de años word con su nuevo
poder oscuro se dedicaría a asesinar a
miles de dioses de todas las culturas
existentes a lo largo del universo hasta
que eventualmente encontró a un joven
sol en la tierra quien aún no había
podido
cuando gore y short se encontraron por
primera vez de inmediato comenzaron a
luchar pero core le rompió toda su
celestial madre pues era mucho más
fuerte que todo tal fue la golpiza que
le dio que casi mata al dios del rayo
pero cuando estaba a punto de morir todo
limbo con poderoso rayo que los impactó
a ambos dejándolos inconscientes
poco tiempo después todo volvería a
encontrarse con gore en una cueva en
donde volverían a luchar pero nuevamente
kurt le da una paliza
al derrotar a short gordo en cadena y lo
tortura durante 17 días todo para que le
diga dónde se encuentran los demás
dioses asgard ya no si así pueda ir a
matarlos pero todo es muy macizo y
aguanta la tortura como el cabrón que es
cierto que más piso luego de 17 días los
seguidores vikingos de thor pudieron
encontrarlo y con su ayuda solo pudo
liberarse y atacar por sorpresa a core
cortándole su brazo derecho pero como
sólo es medio [ __ ] lo da por muerto y
decide marcharse nadie me dice que tan
imbécil puede ser obviamente gordo
sobrevive y gracias a la necro espada
regenera su brazo y se recupera
totalmente pasando los siguientes mil
años asesinando a cientos de dioses
haciéndose cada vez más fuerte una
eternidad más táctil luego de estos mil
años en el presente por quien ahora sí
empuña almidones se dedica a realizar
una búsqueda para encontrar agua y
detenerlo de una vez por todas
descubriendo en el camino un lugar en
donde habían muchos dioses de distintas
mitologías torturados y asesinados
por su poca gordo había regresado
mientras todo lo estaba buscando por
viejo a donde se encontraban unos dioses
del tiempo a quienes obligó a que lo
ayudaran a crear un portal para volver
atrás en el tiempo a el momento de la
creación del universo en donde él
arrancó el corazón a un dios antiguo
luego core viaja miles de años hacia un
futuro en donde mató a casi todos los
dioses en existencia y tiene como
esclavos a los pocos que quedan por
decide quedarse en el futuro y usa el
corazón del dios antiguo para crear una
bomba lo suficientemente poderosa como
para matar a todos los dioses a lo largo
de todos los universos aquí con el poder
de la necro espada war crea un ejército
de criaturas oscuras llamadas berserkers
que seguirían todas sus órdenes y
también crearía copias exactas de su
fallecida esposa y de uno de sus hijos
en este futuro al que gorbea juego
solamente queda un dios que sigue
luchando contra el sol quien estando
odín muerto se convirtió en el padre de
todo esta versión de azor luchó por años
con los berserkers pero finalmente fue
derrotado y fue reclutado como uno de
los esclavos del cubo
ahora aquí es cuando las cosas se ponen
un tanto extrañas por todo esto de los
viajes en el tiempo word decide volver
al presente para buscar más materiales
para la bomba pero es aquí cuando el sol
del presente lo encuentra y vuelven a
luchar pero cuando word trata de huir
solos y que a través del portal del
tiempo y termina en el futuro en donde
se encuentra con el sol de este mundo
aquí mientras los dos comienzan a crear
un plan para detener la bomba igor
decide volver en el tiempo una vez más y
secuestra al zor del pasado con el que
había luchado hace miles de años pues
quiere que él vea con sus propios ojos
como la bomba estalla y los dioses dejan
de existir
esto por supuesto resulta ser una mala
idea pase al ser joven escapa y termina
reuniéndose con sus otras dos versiones
furiosos el sol del pasado el del
presente y el del futuro unen fuerzas y
deciden atacar juntos a word para poder
derrotarlo y aunque al principio lo
superan en fuerza y están a punto de
rotarlo por le ordena a los berserkers
que sacrifiquen a los demás dioses que
tenía como esclavos y así la necro
espada absorbe la fuerza de los dioses
sacrifica 2 y con todo este poder ni las
tres versiones de dos juntas pudieron
hacerle frente pues logró derrotarlos a
los tres al mismo tiempo hijo de [ __ ]
madre
al ver esto la esposa de gordo ahora de
alegría diciendo que el gor se había
convertido en su dios al oír esto cord
enloqueció y en frente de su hijo
asesinó inmediatamente a su esposa antes
de decirle yo no soy el dios de nadie
besos si este cáncer de casters cuando
el hijo de gor vio lo que se había
convertido su padre y lo mucho que había
enloquecido decidió ayudar al zor del
presente y otorgarle la habilidad de
soportar la explosión de la bomba
inmediatamente fort empuñando ahora dos
martillos el de él y el de su versión
del futuro se lanzó de inmediato hacia
la bomba y lanzó un ataque tan poderoso
que logró debilitar lo suficiente agua
como para arrebatarle la necro espada y
al mismo tiempo absorber todo el poder
de la bomba ahora más poderoso que nunca
con dos martillos unido a la necro
espada y viéndose de [ __ ] madre sólo le
lanza un poderoso ataque a war que lo
deja al borde de la muerte mientras
guardias en el suelo su hijo le dice lo
decepcionado que está de él y enseguida
desaparece pues la necro espada era lo
único que lo mantenía con vida gorce
lamenta y grita con rabia y tristeza por
haberlo perdido todo por su locura pero
rápidamente el sol del pasado decapitado
finalmente acabando con su sufrimiento
y esta es la historia de gor el
carnicero de dioses igor es para mí uno
de los mejores villanos que ha tenido
todo pues tiene una historia muy triste
con la que de inmediato puedes enfatizar
no crees que lo que hizo estuviera bien
pero entiendes por qué lo hizo es como
está no espero gris más allá de ser un
villano que quiere ser malo porque si
logras entender sus motivaciones y lo
que nos llevó a la locura además de que
el tipo logra ser una amenaza enorme no
sólo para azor sino para toda su línea
temporal pues war en su historia llega a
ser uno de los villanos más poderosos
con los que ha luchado con un [ __ ]
derrota a tres versiones de fútbol al
mismo tiempo
de esos días de cáncer de cáncer
gore es un ser supremamente fuerte sí
pero absolutamente todas sus habilidades
las obtiene gracias a la necro espada
pues sin ella no sería más fuerte que un
humano normal y eso sería prácticamente
todo acerca de gordo el carnicero de
dioses pues al fin y al cabo él no es
una entidad cósmica un dios o nada por
el estilo es solamente un pobre ser con
muy mala suerte que quería vengarse de
los dioses todo lo que yo te conté es un
muy breve resumen de la historia de gor
así que te recomiendo muchísimo leer la
historia por ti mismo en serio es muy
entretenida de leer y por supuesto para
que entiendas completamente la historia
de gor y de dónde proviene su poder te
recomiendo mucho que veas el vídeo que
hice acerca de nul el dios de los
simbiontes desde hace tiempo ya se
confirmó que bruce wayne interpretaría a
core el carnicero de los dioses en la
cuarta película de thor ahora esperemos
que la película le haga justicia a este
gran personaje así que nos vemos en el
cine hasta la próxima
[Música]